I grew up just
absolutely loving movies.
My first movie that my
dad took me to was E.T.,
and I had a popcorn
bucket, like, up to here.
I could barely see over it.
Really the thing that got
me into visual effects
is how it is a blend of
artistry and technology.
We create an illusion
that transports people
into a different place.
In 2010, we created
Atomic Fiction,
which is a visual effects
and animation studio.
One of the most challenging
parts of doing visual effects
is called rendering.
That process can take
anywhere between 2 minutes
and 40 hours for every
single frame, every 24th
of a second of a film.
Rendering takes an immense
amount of computing horsepower.
Using Google Cloud Platform
to do our rendering,
we have massive infrastructure
offsite when we need it
and then nothing when we don't.
It allows us to use computers
for minutes at a time
and only get billed
for what we use.
And so we took that
as an opportunity
to create our own tool set
more specific to our industry
called Conductor, which runs on
top of Google's Cloud Platform.
It helped us put the resources
on where it was important--
the artists-- and making
sure that every penny
that our clients spent
made it up on the screen.
These movies that might have
otherwise been bottled up
in a filmmaker's mind are
now actually seeing the light
of day on the movie screen.
There's no greater satisfaction
than creating a visual effect
that people just believe
that they're somewhere else.
That's what we do is
we create fiction.
Hopefully it's just the
most believable fiction
that you can imagine.